there's been a bunch of reports about
these British female jihadists that are
basically leading Iraqi women into
sexual slavery so let's let's take a
look at some info on this so they're
members of an ultra religious Islamic
state police force tasked with looking
after girls captured from the Yazidi
tribe in Iraq the Yazidis were the ones
that were trapped on the mountain and
then world outrage came and we actually
did do some airstrikes that's what sort
of started this whole thing as many as
three thousand Iraqi women have been
taken into captive in the last two weeks
by the terror group and sources suggest
the members of the all women Brigade in
Raqqa Syria are running brothels to
satisfy the fighters desires and one of
the sources has a quote in the Daily
Mirror these women are using barbaric
interpretations of the Islamic faith to
justify their actions they believe the
militants can use the women as they
please they are non-muslims these IDI
people are being ethnically cleansed and
their women are being subjected to the
most brutal treatment it is the British
women who have risen up to the top of
the Islamic states Sharia police and now
they are in charge of this operation it
is as bizarre as it is perverse so what
I kind of thought was interesting here
is that the women that are in charge of
basically the sex slavery operation
they're the ones coming from the West
coming from Britain doesn't that seem
particularly Oh
certainly because there is no history of
what European folk thinking that the
darker skinned people of far-off places
can be used as slaves that's a whole new
idea to che dealin Brody III think
clearly if it's about the abuse of women
this should result immediately in the
firing of the Commissioner of the NFL
yeah good luck with that that's not this
is another one of those things where we
are selectively outraged yeah you know
it's not as though our soldiers in
far-off lands are always kind and
generous and bringing flowers and
chocolate and nylons to the women around
them yeah when we cover up war crimes
all the time because once you start
dehumanizing people which is necessary
for an act of war you begin treating
them as less than human
what do you what do you guys think that
was appealing to women about this I can
sorta see you know they keep saying that
there's all these foreign fighters that
are joining Isis that they're coming
from America they're coming from France
and England and all that I can sort of
see it with a young male that I guess is
maybe frustrated with not being
integrated in society and economic
problems on that somehow it seems a lot
weirder to me for a woman and maybe I
maybe there's some underlying sexism
there I feel the same way when I look at
fundamentalist Christianity that talks
about women's subjecting themselves to
their men's whims I feel the same way
when I look at any of the the
patriarchal systems that a great many
women buy into it there is always a
segment of humanity of any part of
humanity that is happier taking up a
position of a followership
and it's no weirder to me than any other
self-sabotaging minority it's a it's a
very mind controlled culture and you can
make people do a lot of things that
doesn't seem to be in the normal human
format you know kill yourself blow a lot
of people up at once that it is possible
to reprogram people to do things yeah
and so certainly the Stockholm Syndrome
would seem like an easy one in that
setting and if you've got British women
who are moving into a culture that's
incredibly repressive toward women and
they're suddenly given a place to have
power they're gonna slide into that
position and there was that study done
with the college students in the US with
the electrical truck much later than
that one with the prison guards and
prisoners selected at random and the
ones were prison guards within like a
day and a half we're starting to be
tyrants and and they were all falling
into their roles you people people are
weird you've given me a perfect out
there people are weird and don't you
forget it
[Music]